and we are so excited to announce this
year's Oscar nominees so let's not keep
anyone else out there waiting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes me nominated any shoplifter Stanley
has an almost 62 year-old man having an
Oscar nomination
[Music]
[Applause]
do you understand English
absolutely mapa good lord
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
co-chair of the Foreign Language Film
Award Executive Committee and Academy
vice president Larry karaszewski good
evening I want to thank you all for
coming that helped the Academy celebrate
the Oscar nominees for Best Foreign
Language Film and on behalf of the
entire foreign language committee and my
co-chair who is here tonight Diane
wireman we'd like to give a warm welcome
to the cast and crew members of the five
nominated films that are here with us
tonight yes your work was extraordinary
there's been some amazing motion
pictures in the foreign language
division this year but what's also
amazing is that they've received
nominations in so many other Oscar
categories including Best Picture there
are three nominees for cinematography
there are two nominees for Best Director
there are two nominees in the in the
acting divisions
I mean Sinemet on my resume at ography
but like in screenwriting in sound and
editing it just goes on and on make up
the Academy really embraced these films
this year and I want to tell you a
little bit about how this division works
because I don't think that many people
really know how the foreign language
division works
it started out for us back in October
and 87 countries sent us their best and
then five or six times a week
our group would meet here or in the
Lynwood done theater over in Hollywood
and we screened every movie this is one
of the very last divisions that insists
that if you're going to vote you have to
see each film projected on the big
screen it takes two or three months but
it really is the greatest Film Festival
on the planet it's it's really a joy the
and this year particularly we knew right
away we had an embarrassment of riches
the very first night the very first film
that screened was shoplifters our
eventual nominee from Japan but really
almost every night we would turn you
know the lights would come back on and
we turn to the person sitting next to us
and say wow that was amazing well that
movie has to be one of the nominees but
you can't have 87 nominees particularly
if you're trying to do a three hour
telecast you definitely can't have 87
foreign language film nominees so it was
very difficult but we the first group
managed to get that down from 87 to a
shortlist of nine and then at that point
we brought in the International Academy
members because we really felt that this
category needs to have a global voice
many of the international members are
former nominees in this category many of
the international members are former
winners in this category and they're the
ones who helped us narrow it down to
these five amazing films it's a long
process and a very busy time of the year
but we get through it because we have
such a helpful staff here at the Academy
and this year I'm very proud to say we
had a record number of a Cadillac Adam
II members being involved we had 700
Academy members volunteer to be a part
of this process and yes actually if you
are in the audience we have a lot of
these voters who are in the audience
tonight if you were a person who who
helped out in the account and the
language division this year can you
please stand so we can give you a round
of applause for thanks now in a few
minutes I'm going to bring in the
filmmakers to discuss how they made
these films but first we want to show
you some clips to give you a taste of
this extraordinary work thank you
from Germany never look away florian
henckel von donnersmarck writer director
producer
[Applause]
in cliche fanclub at the luftwaffe is
fair and miserable Ivanka own might be
Lord for and mr. happy nappy Lord Shiva
hospital heart flesh bones and fat
enhancers wouldn't be a pleasure to
Liberty cream the balut was a fifty
visual phenomena centered on Austin
rapper bog with phenomena and English
admission status diba one can now Depot
and digital bomb battlezone so Misha
steam block conflict mesh with invasion
your even my nirvana me fed iron
if we couldn't mission feel stick
[Music]
should keep any pain then I pick up his
machine and I can trigger functions
[Music]
wenn ich mich Hagen as his fetish face
as he mentally she and funda not being
named as he spoke didn't come on it's
illegal
then he sisters fit of my now yeah I am
at his face on his fiercest we may under
her from be bad sailor to found so
easily kinder where the fans axed and
vice ish was in meinem new vanish fields
effect of minor hawkish Goethe
yep the phony silly when Akeem that
fabulous polluted and thought was I
convening here and they didn't talk to
me she before the Calphalon V&V man
father Shattuck and could still just an
end 20 Sheva citing initially she
faithfully she could bleed was clear
enough apart
um lots ahead with frontage accomplished
Western Xia foraging hunt miss Western
the knowledge they never fortuned this
Apophis sewer here
to sit until fields Yebisu Durst woman
Theresa first and v/vt car first and not
a say exist yet
if think as a finish they had artisan
finishes Alice Alice continues yawns
ahem talk unbidden but Andrew steered us
here again adversities a Gedanken
understand but as far please Gigandet
were sexist illness when thesis here the
necklace does Linda ish all of em is too
fast pistol
does bestow niched
from Japan shoplifters hirokazu Cory ADA
writer/director
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you got that i sat there cannot cannot
see me then another still a long sort of
a poster got a spoon of America
hi
from Lebanon capper Nahum Nadine labaki
writer/director
nothing much doesn't appreciate
helicopter action love analemma the hell
at the onion let Ali released after the
truce document an ohmmeter hadith had a
stigma failure a leader here is like a
long term we celebrate the rod with
Roberto - human issues of negative
attention today
- saharan directness arrived nefarious
bro haman haman vgj pedrad hi puddin
affirmative of a cafe a vehicle unique
we're a unique usable modular Rotterdam
on TV in a hospital Edmond for the Latin
Aras Ambaji salinas reina sofia diesel
emission vehicle at the Monroe's uncle
is a minimalistic look you know Mercedes
our initials are modulus precision
little markers Robin Solomon chakras
here
summa kalla bosom Freda
yeah
[Music]
my gosh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we must accordion what
from Mexico Roma Alfonso Cuaron writer
director producer
[Music]
Donna Lauria no see
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from Poland Cold War poeple public Oski
writer/director
[Applause]
what is it
much of privacy zap we touch Tommy -
Robbie mm said Parvati mobster Nico I am
a map of eons ago Ahmad fovea judge
Terrace to his vast dome at the three
provisos dispatcher musique est de anza
de Medici
taraji was an Apache Janek Pollock was a
classic Gaddafi projeto was the key
Moloch saved a Pawnee Sonya HD which
make atop solution there as much a
promotion is a protective system am
obsessed at week I have a motto iam
absolutely no sister telco nightlapse
eat my laps evaded us Road car he
patronum orcam nasi padang Go Go
Croatoan astrid the Polsky it's all
about the curves even was the versus
Glendale Isla had a bulky the servo in
Mendizabal
con yet traditional awesome yankov Musa
countess hoorah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
[Music]
Bardot funny bunnies drift go to Panama
Bobby come on oh gosh yeah Paco he saw
gaga blue blue button T&E portraits
Epoque oh yeah see a cockroach honest
with you judge see a garage to do the
koi spa see Monsieur studio mr. Szpilman
but even enough she said Kim kinam
obvious Davao me because a very risky
film
she had fish me on a Tom Dora your
something is only washed you know said
sir when he's dying sir was an ample to
stop of a fetish democracy no voltage
until she hit him
like this
can't we just have a five-way tie I mean
I mean the movies are just incredible
and one thing I thought while I was
watching those clips is the word foreign
is in the title of the category but
there's nothing foreign about anything
we just watched they all tackle
universal themes of love and family and
have so much empathy for the human
condition
I'm blown away by these movies so let's
bring out the filmmakers from Germany
the director of never look away florian
henckel von donnersmarck I'm bringing
them out in order of height that's how
we as Howard that's how we're doing it
from Mexico the director of Roma Alfonso
korone
hello from Lebanon the director of
Capernaum
Nadine labaki
from Poland the director of cold war
pavel [ __ ] hausky and from japan the
director of shoplifters hero Kazu Corita
welcome everyone have a seat have a seat
just think the Oscars are only a few
days away this may well be your last Q&A
I mean some of you have been doing this
for a year like some there are some
movies here from Khan last year you were
literally been on this journey for such
a long time so well we'll try to keep
this short so you and you can be done
I'm also gonna try to ask questions that
you all can answer but I'm trying to try
to be specific as well I'm gonna start
off with um why now why was this film
important for you to make what was what
was it that got your passion going to to
actually tackle something what was the
inspiration was a genesis I'll start
with you
actually your film is a little different
where that is a clear sense of
inspiration in your movie with the work
of gerhard richter mm-hmm yeah i mean
you know now is always a relative thing
because you know now is when it comes
out but it's four years ago that I
started working on it so so so now is
quite stretched you know I mean I think
it really is I mean it had the original
idea for this about ten years ago or so
and then you know you live with many
different ideas and then a time comes
where you find yourself you know going
to sleep thinking about an idea and then
you wake up in the morning and you think
about the idea and then you realize if
that goes on for a few weeks then it's
almost more like the story chooses you
and and I think that's sometimes that's
kind of that's the beauty I think of if
it that you can choose something and you
don't even exactly know why you feel it
so so relevant and and so I mean you
mentioned all the
I actually find that really interesting
because I tried to use it as an
opportunity to think myself about why
would I embark on such a crazy adventure
of spending so much time on and so much
energy and you know everything I have
and that my family has on a you know on
a movie you know it's kind of
interesting to ask yourself why you
would embark on something like that so
that's crazy no matter what happens oh
yes I mean it's it's you know it doesn't
seem like a rational thing to do in a
way tell his story I'm you know
especially in an embattled art form like
like movies right right now you know it
certainly doesn't and but you know
there's something I know you know when I
when I I've been thinking a lot about it
over the past weeks because and I and I
think in a certain way I mean it's a
film about art and and I think that
you're one thing that I noticed when
studying various dictatorships was the
first thing that dictatorships come
after is art they want to control that
and it's almost like you know like in a
fantasy movie or something when an evil
creature touches something it withers
away you know as soon as a dictatorship
touches art it ceases to be art you know
it disappears and so you know there this
means that there's something about art
which is fundamental to freedom and and
it's still the best weapon that we have
against political extremism and so you
know I wanted to explore that Alfonso
what made you take such a deep dive into
your childhood I had this project like
first time I thought about doing it was
2006 probably and I didn't dare to do it
so I could say to give the answer that I
was in a moment that I had to do it
because of age and so on and I really
had to do it but I guess that it was
more about I couldn't find excuses not
to do it anymore
yeah and and that's the reason why I did
it pretty much and is one of those that
I didn't think twice I just dove into it
and
without really understanding what I was
doing and was that was refreshing in in
my process because I used to be very
controlling about the process and in
this one I didn't have any control of it
Nadine how did you add you how capernum
come to you
Capernaum at at some point and in my
life started becoming a duty for me I I
didn't it wasn't even a choice for me I
had to do this film I had to because in
Lebanon you know you're exposed to
children suffering every day almost you
visited detention centers correct not
only that because you know you you see
children on the streets begging or
selling gum or selling flowers or
carrying heavy loads or carrying gas
tanks or so you see this and I think
that when you see a child suffering you
can't help but just want to do something
about it and I think I truly believe in
the power of cinema I truly believe that
if film can actually change things
change people's perceptions and and and
I I just decided to use my tool I felt
responsible in a way for the scales that
we are living in especially in Lebanon
because of the Syrian refugee crisis you
know Lebanon has hosted over a million
and a half refugees it's almost half the
population in comparison with this
population so so the the economical
crisis is really reflecting mostly on
children and when you see a child
suffering I think you just can't help
but want to do something about it and I
just decided to use my tool which is
filmmaking and I just decided to make a
film about that and just in a way
humanize it humanize the problem because
obviously when you think about the
problem you want to do something every
every one of us want to do something
about it but you feel like the problem
is so big and the problem is is a little
bit abstract you don't know where to
start and end a film
actually you can humanize the problem
you can really empathize with the
character you understand the struggle
and and and and I truly believe that it
does have an impact on you as a human
being when you you and you're actually
seeing it and and in this particular
situation the actors are not actors
they're actually people who are living
that same struggle and when you're
watching it on the big screen and you
know that this is an actual struggle
it's an actual is this is actually
somebody who is living that struggle it
does have a completely different impact
on you and and you I think
empathize differently so it really felt
like you know I just want to do
something about it it was a duty you
felt yes
Pawel what made you have to make this
movie it's it's slightly based on your
parents correct slightly it's been a
story that's has been with me for a long
time the story of this kind of couple in
other words my parents and there I've
been putting it off and I couldn't get
it right and I was being literal about
this story and it's an amazing story
that has so many sides to it and a bit
like I found so there's a moment where I
couldn't not do it and especially since
I suddenly I felt confident about my
tools you know I kind of felt you know I
can work something out with either
previous film and I knew I can sort of I
know more or less how to do it not
entirely but I was I felt I could do it
and then then I added the music and kind
of simplified the whole story and you
know and this was the right moment to do
it I mean there's no no but it's been
with me for maybe ten years there's this
kind of story here okazu
what what made you decide to make
shoplifters
I know Sakura mochi food hands I'd its
Naruto you know very tight on wa makara
gonna and Magnus
you know Cory automata h1 motivation
when Anakin team Academy little I know
starts kicking in Santo joyoung car San
Antonio cohutta's Nina cañada Ritesh
Martinez Meccano Janine Cundy no pony
show Nisa keynotes could never stay mad
cause I go Conakry okinawa navara no
ghost and eskimo prom consider it a
tamato achieve a national hockey
motivation in japan cheney a timid
stanchion I cannot even maritime I can
get it
the question is why now why would I do
this now I had certainly been thinking
for some time about creating a family
that was connected through crime for
about four years I was thinking about
how to portray this but now that I think
about it as you asked me perhaps the
motivation was more about Kiki kidding
so she passed away in September and we
had been working together on the last
six films - with each other and each
time I thought will this be our last
will this be our last and so when I
started thinking about producing this
film I think the motivation for it was
to do one more film with her well she's
really the heart of your movie your
beautiful film the next question is and
I'm a screenwriter so it's a
screenwriting question all of you wrote
the scripts or co-wrote
your screenplays how important was it
for you to get it down right on paper I
mean some of your films feel very
improvised and very sort of found but
they also are extremely precise I mean
I'll start start with you Alfonso III
I could be wrong but I understand that
you actually wrote a very very detailed
screenplay but then you didn't show it
to anybody
yeah the screenplay was a the process of
writing and reality was very short was
like three weeks but the process of
thinking about it was like a very long
process and once that and I wanted to go
directly from those memories and that
directly into the page untainted and
then try to translate that later on into
into the film and the reason of not
showing it is I didn't want to be
sidetracked right you know I wanted it
to use in one hand I didn't want it to
be sidetracked I didn't usually I I
share my screenplay with collaborators
that kill my screenplays like he's a
killer you know it's a no you hand your
script to people who who are tough on
you can take away you joy we share the
screenplays the power gift try to save
him a lot of time and pain but then in
this one I didn't want that because I
knew that either he was going to
convince me one more time not to do that
film or or or he was going to give me
amazing notes that probably would not
make the film a better film a better
screenplay but it would be far drifting
from that essence that I was after right
well what's interesting in your film is
not necessarily plot driven as much it's
the movie about space it's about time
and so it's actually I haven't read your
screenplay but you know it that's
something that doesn't it's very
difficult to translate onto the page
well I I was aware of that and and I
decided to make very long descriptions
also broke the rules of screenwriting
compeition screenwriting in which smells
are described you know it's stuff like
that because it was kind of that essence
that was trying to capture later on
as a director but all the sounds
everything is very very very well
describing the industry Nadine what was
the screenwriting process for you
the screenwriting was happening in
parallel with the research I knew from
the start that we needed to base it on
reality on truth so I felt I wasn't
entitled in a way to imagine the story
or to fictionalize it in my head because
I haven't lived this these circumstances
I had haven't lived this hardship and
deprivation and hunger and all that so
for me I needed to become in a way the
platform or the vehicle for them to
express themselves for all these people
who are who ended up being in the film
to express themselves so it started with
a lot of research so the writing process
was happening in parallel with this
research we would we would used to go
with my co-writers just you know ask
questions meet people spend time with
children children in detention centers
and prisons in those very deprived
neighborhood and slums in Beirut talking
to the parents talking to judges and
lawyers trying to understand the problem
from so many different angles and then
in a way writing the script it was
really ended up being you know weaving
all of those details and those scenes
that we used to witness all together in
a story so it was very much based on
reality the script and it was a very
very solid script to start with but then
also there was a rewriting process
during the shoot because obviously we
were working with non-professional
actors who can't really learn a line you
know most of them didn't even know how
to read so it was I I didn't give anyone
a script they didn't know what was gonna
happen next so because we were shooting
also chronologically I just wanted them
to also because this is how it happens
in real life you don't know what's gonna
happen next and you are informed with
but what happened before so this is what
we were doing and we and there was a
rewriting process the whole time because
there was a lot of improvisation on the
shoot sometimes we would go places that
were not supposed to go to and and I had
you know an amazing crew of people and
and a lot of them are here they were
just you know it's very hard to find a
crew that you know just goes with you
wherever you want to go without any
doubt without any any obstacles just
because they believe in it
so we we improvise a lot even though we
had a very solid script it was a good
starting point and a very good landing
point but in the meantime we just
allowed ourselves and allowed life to
just inform whatever we were doing and
amazing stuff were happening to us the
whole time
I mean the film kept going from reality
to fiction fiction to reality sometimes
we didn't even know what we were
shooting I mean we felt that we were
just capturing truths capturing reality
and it gave us all the strength to just
keep going even though the process was
very long and it was very hard and we
shot for six months you know we have 500
hours of rushes the first the first when
we put everything together it was a 12
hour film really and my editor is here
and he you know he went through so much
hardship you know it was held to him you
know all of us physically we changed
after the film my cinematographer who is
also here lost his beard on this set
because it was so hard my you know line
producer exactly which is everybody it
was here like it was a very very
difficult tough shoot to do because
sometimes we didn't even know what we
were going to shoot tomorrow and we had
like it was so much based on reality
that real things were happening at the
same time you know and those scenes were
the Enochian mother gets arrested in the
film two days later in real life she
gets arrested for the same reasons
because she didn't have papers not only
that the mother and father of the little
boy he was actually a girl in real life
they get arrested with her at the same
time so when we were shooting those
scenes where she is arrested in the film
she's actually arrested in real life
she's in prison at that moment and the
mother and father's also the the mother
of the little girl who's supposed to be
arrested in the film she is arrested in
real life so when we were shooting those
scenes where she's alone without her mom
she was actually alone without her mom
when we were shooting so it kept the
film kept also developing and evolving
this way the whole time so and the third
writing process rewriting process was
happening in the editing room obviously
because we had to you know find the
structure again
exactly Pavel what was the screen
writing for you I mean your film is much
more structured you've got those
narrative jumps you've got you know it's
a it's a it's a it's a very tight film
yes but this structure didn't didn't
occur on the page you know on my laptop
necessarily I mean I had like hundred
and ninety-seven versions of this script
one of them we had to submit something
to define answers I think it must have
been like 79 B or something like so so I
try to did you share it with Alfonso or
it doesn't go one direction
I just told it the story at some point
it is a pretty good story I think that's
the main thing what's the story what are
they how does it end what are the
turning points to the married you talk
is this okay you want he tell the story
and then says you want to send the
screenplay sit what for if anyway then I
don't know what I'm going to do
[Laughter]
so I keep it open you know of course
there's the financier and and basically
I never stop writing you know I mean I
do it with my co-writer at some point to
achieve 62 pages to send to this to the
worried financier it's a bit short but
they know if actually transcribed the
film onto script the finished film it'll
be like 27 pages you know so you know so
for me the whole screenplay concept is a
bit it's a kind of it's a fiction really
but so anyway so then the processed I
start looking for actors I rehearse a
bit I can rewrite a bit because partly
because of what happens in rehearsals
partly buys me time to think you know
now I look for locations and driving
around gives you ideas you know and and
and again time time is their key thing
you know you get bored with stuff that
wasn't so brilliant was great at the
time new things occur then you start
shooting and I have this strategy now
which I worked out with my mic producers
who I here have you know gracefully
allowed me this to shoot five-day weeks
and have one day to rest and one day to
cut and rewrite so I constantly go back
on myself or tweak this and that stuff
they haven't shot yet but the film which
I'm shooting already has a life of its
own so I'm trying to be faithful to the
film and suddenly it's clear what the
mistakes are because the film starts to
kind of telling me what to do and
there's a beautiful point when you start
making if and when actually the film
starts telling you you know what to do
and of course if you stuck with a
mediocre or bad script and you can't do
that you know and I think that's the
problem with most film films the
executor script doesn't necessarily work
so and then we had gaps in production
here we move locations a lot and we had
to wait for the weather to change and
all these gaps I was kind of cutting and
rewriting and
adding taking away cutting scenes that I
put to the back of the schedule because
I knew they're a bit sketchy or kind of
functional more than beautiful and
poetic so it's a kind of constant
tutoring and froing
and it's not life that gives me stuff
it's time and the film itself you know
are you a musician brilliant one day
right but not that you've done I mean
your film as bit as well as oftentimes
musical and so I was you know but that
was all the musical thing about sure who
thing yeah hero Kazu I'm actually
completely fascinated with how you make
movies I understand that you you you you
write and shoot kind of at the same time
I understand that like the beach scene I
might have been one of the very first
scenes that you shot and then you
started you started writing at night to
match scenes with that scene or I mean I
could be being wrong but I understand
that you you write and shoot as you go
along how what is your process as a
screenwriter filmmaker
I know get some oh no no I only try to
state their money touched I didn't at
the montseny got distracted so just
listening to the way you were talking
about your filming well it was very much
similar to that I think it's like the
movie is a living thing that you're
constantly changing with and I feel that
the way I approach it it's very much the
same
those two mahaki teens on a second
chance kiddo
so you need an example - sorry -
catarata notte e mod will be a machine
it's hidden asto it's a Danish on each
their solution is in ecology which one's
evil not
- sigh oh no she knocks a can I call mr.
Kashi so Cody I know mother
yakumo I know skaldak they enacted in I
drank I did not know she no she knocked
on so called a kanojo God nobody your
son they just say anemic at cane and
cleaning the Kyoto got the ax in this
kid Mario was I much that it's a vehicle
the scatman so no studs no sir if I hide
enacted cannot yoga Shivan the militia
veterans name
sorry okay to meet me so no - entitle
machine image the codes could take until
so you call Akshay no chikara text on
Nakamura the Sakina acoustic so you call
uber oh come on Tony
I know Sheena so I end up talking about
Kiki Killian again because she was very
much similar that way that she would go
into the set and the filming of that day
with a very unique feeling towards it so
that particular scene going back to the
beach scene that you were talking about
it was a difficult scene I think for her
to take because it was the first thing
we shot but it would be the last scene
for her her in the film and she must
have thought a lot about how she wanted
to do it so there's a line that says she
turns to know beyond says oh your face
is so beautiful and then there's another
one where she doesn't say it out loud
but she sort of mouthed the words thank
you in Japanese and actually I had
written neither of those in the script
she invented that and it was only later
when I went back and reviewed the
film that I noticed that it had she had
added that element on the spot to it and
based on that I had to rewrite it and so
to me it's like an organic kind of
process where you sort of do catch ball
between what the actor is doing then you
take it back and then you rewrite it and
that process keeps going and when it
works well it's a very happy a very good
process Florian
what was your process like well I mean I
think my answer will be a very Germanic
answer because it's so radically
different yes
anyway the screenplay I I really do
believe in story and in screenplay and
and you know having it all kind of
figure it out before before I approached
someone about it and but I really I mean
I think it's a it's a constitutional
thing with me I really think in stories
you know I mean that's really that's how
I look at life and you know I find it
it's the only way I can make sense of
life if you know so and that is what so
I always start on a screenplay I always
start with the ending I mean not
actually writing it but I have that in
mind I always know that I have a good
idea or an idea that is satisfying to me
and that I hope will you know appeal to
the actors when I have the ending in
mind that I often actually often have
that situation when people submit
screenplays to directors I often hear
them say oh you know what I mean the
ending needs work but you know the first
two acts are great or so but if you
don't have an ending you have nothing
you really don't have it's it's and so
you know I start from that point and you
know way when I when I when I went about
this this film and I had you know an
ending very clearly in mind I I really
had this thought that in wade towards
the end all the elements that we've seen
in this film you know where you really
think my god why is this guy going
through so much pointless suffering in
the end it all comes together and
suddenly make sense and through the art
that is possible only because of all
this suffering suddenly you realize
every little last bit that this person
was necessary for him to be able to
create this art which allows him to
defeat his greatest enemy you know
through art once I you know had that in
place I thought okay how am I going to
go about this and I you know I looked
back to how you know what a terrible
experience it was just writing the lives
of others because you know it just took
very long and then I thought you know
what wasn't really that took so long why
did it take me years to write this
screenplay
yeah and and why did I go to so many
drafts because I actually had this thing
that after I'd finished the whole film
on the lives of others I went back to
the to the I think it was draft maybe
you know 970 like with Papa but it was I
don't maybe draft 20 or something like
that
I I went back and looked at draft one I
saw you know it was almost everything
was there and I think why did I go
through those years of suffering and so
I decided for myself you know to set an
arbitrary limit you know I I knew that I
know I can write very fast so you know
the first draft of the lives of others I
wrote in a monk's cell in one month but
then I decided okay you know I'll do a
compromise I'll say I said for myself an
arbitrary limit I said you know that in
the time that it takes you know one body
to weave another nine months you know
that's I'll set that as an arbitrary
limit for myself and then you know I
just I I really worked on it for nine
months and then just you know on exactly
nine months to the day I shut the
computer and said that's it and I
actually went to my producers quieren
Berg and Max Vita men who are both here
and said to them okay this is what I'd
like to do you know the one thing if you
know if it appeals to you that you know
I need you to promise is that I can
shoot it exactly as is because you know
there's always this this question you
know do you really need this I mean you
don't really need anything right I mean
yeah evil line producers not uh you know
it's not we're not let's combine these
three things no I mean it's not it's
it's not that the it is the the
superfluous is what makes the essence
you know of something special I mean you
know you could boy-meets-girl can just
be that high on the boy on the girl yeah
that's it you know I mean you don't need
anything right so you know
you you so I just after you know after
nine months I said that's it and
actually you know but I had it so
clearly in mind that actually when I
before I started writing I needed to you
know the only person who at that point
had really read anything was my wife
Christiana also one of the producers
also here she was the only pun would
kind of read it and given feedback as we
were as I was writing but then I
actually so before I wrote it I knew
there were two people that I really
needed to have on board and that was my
director of photography Caleb Deschanel
he was also here also nominated and we
had you know III didn't have a second
choice in my mind of who could
photograph this because I knew it had it
was about images about the creation of
images I needed moving paintings and and
I know that that's what he creates and
that's what he's you know always moved
me with throughout his whole career so I
met with him beforehand and four years
ago and and just pitched to him the
entire story actually here at the farm
shop in Los Angeles out of where we had
a breakfast meeting which went on I
think until 1:00 then because it took I
think four hours to tell him the story
we just this morning we'd we had a date
to have a commemorative meeting for
years on at the exact place and and had
breakfast together and and and the other
person was a bastion called my lead
actor because I needed him to play the
villain and he said why the villain but
I said to me you know why and then he
and he agreed to do it and so then you
know I knew that I had the the elements
in place that that I had and and then
you know that I knew I could confidently
go into writing this and really
achieving what I what point did you did
you you talked to Richter what what
point did you see if they would be open
to having his story here's part because
I knew interpreting his story but yeah I
mean I met with a lot of artists but he
was the one who was the most generous
with his time so I spent but this was
during the research phase so before I
really you know embarked on the
nine-month journey I spent about half a
year researching I mean I you know it
was a it was a topic and a
and a scene that I was had become quite
familiar with over the past years but
you know I needed to dive deeply into it
there were some seminal works that I
needed to read and you know a lot of
artists that I had to meet and since the
initial idea was inspired by Garrett
Richter the great German painters work I
thought it would also be you know
interesting to throw what I had made of
these real elements from his life let's
say the fiction that we've to throw that
at him and see from his reaction you
know if there was you know where maybe
where there was some reality texture to
it I loved in using real elements in
fiction because I think it kind of
allows you to to test the stuff of which
you've woven your fiction you know to
see if the if the if the fact fits right
in then you know it's a it's a good
texture so he was you know I that was in
the research in the research phase next
question is about the performances I
mean the performances in all five movies
are just extraordinary some of the the
great female performances of our time
are in these films and it's such a crazy
mixture here of some of the best actors
in the world and people making their
first film people complete non prose and
so like you all to talk about your casts
and and and how you work with actors and
we'll start with even a Dean because you
are an actress you're actually in the
film but really before you even begin I
just want to bow to you in terms of like
you get the most amazing performance out
of an infant and I don't know how I
don't know how you you direct a baby how
do you give notes to me you know it's
the little baby's name is treasure okay
this is where it all starts she was a
real treasure
and I think at that point of my life I
was I mean it might sound cliche but
love is very important this love
relationship that you create with your
characters with with the people you're
going to work with and this fascination
for human nature this fascination for
raw human nature and there's no I mean
children are just they make the most
sense I think in the way they react not
on the way they act and the way they
react to certain situations because they
are not informed by society's codes or
society's politics and hypocrisy and
they're just raw nature so it's you
really know how you have to know how to
just create the right situations for
them to simply react the right way
because whatever they do when they're
being themselves makes sense so when
you're working with a child you're
working with raw nature you just have to
know how to create the right situations
and and maybe the fact that I was also
at that point my own daughter was the
same age as treasurer and I was
breastfeeding her also at the same time
and I was in a way I was seeing myself
and rahael when she was you know taking
care of her baby and nurturing her baby
and breastfeeding her baby she was like
a mirror to me in a way and I think that
if I was not going through the exact
same experience at that point in my life
I wouldn't have maybe captured those
moments so truthfully because I know
what was going on I know what was going
on in the body of this woman at that
point of her life at that period of her
life and I because I was going through
the same thing and I wouldn't have I I
think I wouldn't have known so deeply
what happens with the baby
also in this situation I knew
when she was gonna be sleepy when she
was gonna be hungry when she was gonna
be moody when she's gonna be angry I
knew when she was going to put her hand
on her mother's breasts because my baby
was doing the same thing also with me so
it was I don't know there was a visceral
connection to that whole thing that
allowed me to draw these you know
performances out of treasure out of Zane
and I also helped how do you find
someone like Zane how do you do that I
mean that's I mean you know caperna
means chaos and miracles because it's
it's a town that was cursed by Jesus and
but it is it's where he made his first
miracle so it's and we were were meeting
miracles in this chaos every day every
day so for me the way we found sane and
Zane is a miracle by himself because of
the resilience that he has the bravery
he has and then as a Syrian refugee and
he came to Lebanon he was four years old
or five years old he flew to the war in
Syria and he lived in Lebanon and very
difficult circumstances and
circumstances that are harsher than what
you see in the film the house he lives
in he used to live in is worse than the
house you see in the film he never slept
on a bed saying until he was 12 so his
life was very difficult he used to
really fight his his way out every day
because he didn't go to school he was
deprived from going to school so he grew
up on the streets and growing up on the
streets and in those circumstances
really difficult when you see these kids
fighting with so much violence when you
see the abuse that they have to face
every day the mistreatment sometimes the
rape sometimes the beating sometimes you
have to be very strong and and so Zane
was very strong was he's was very wise
and and he he
looked much younger than his age because
of malnutrition so he was 12 when he was
shooting the film he looked like he was
7 or 8 years old so when you see this
wisdom coming out of this boy who's so
small it's a miracle in itself so so my
casting director saw him we did like
wild street casting of course it doesn't
work it up it's not like they come and
audition for you you have to go find
them in real life so so she found him
and and she interviewed him she I mean
it was obvious that he had something and
I as soon as I saw the interview
everything you know for me it was the
pieces of the puzzle that come together
I knew that we had found him he's got a
light he's he's just because he's been
through so much in his life he's so wise
and he's he's not a child anymore he's
just an adult and she like now I mean I
actually the first time I saw the film
is that the Egyptian and and you were
doing a Q&A and Zayn came up with you
and it was such a after seeing that
movie they have your whole heart torn
out it was like oh my gosh he's a kid
wearing a little suit yeah what what
what's his life he's actually on his on
the plane coming here Wow
yes he's gonna arrive in like maybe one
or two hours he's gonna be here yeah
howdy how's he taking in all this very
very he's a very tough kid you know it's
just very cool with everything he's he's
now living in Norway
he's been resettled with all his family
in Norway he's going to school now and
actually you know when the moment when
he when we knew about the nominations
I called xenon on whatsapp you know
video and he opens the what's up and
he's actually in the classroom with his
friends and they had open up a laptop
and they were waiting for the results at
the same time of the apart and so we
were like it was for me it was another
miracle you know he's not on the streets
fighting with knifes he's in a classroom
and he has a completely different life
in that life now and he's coping very
well with everything that's happening to
him he's he's cool he's good he's not
impressed with anything you know
yeah can you talk about casting your
film pavel you actually wrote your movie
with your lead actress in mind correct
or you had heard mine as you were as you
were conceiving it sorry at some point I
I thought she'd be great and that I
could imagine her doing certain things
that that Zula was doing in an indie
script and and I've always wanted to
work with her in fact I worked with her
twice before when she had smaller parts
so at some point I knew I had the engine
the emotional engine for the film you
know this great actress character was
kind of a lot of charm authenticity who
was not just the professional actress in
her she's a character
she's a force so it was something to
build on I mean the character in the
film is has so many facets so there's
there's a whole process beyond that how
do we then create the Zula who's a
little bit sardonic a little bit cynical
you know so there's a whole process you
know and then whatever works you know
and I made you on I look at Lauren
Bacall on YouTube oh yeah Wow these
scenes because you know that's one thing
she didn't have in her repertoire this
sardonic kind of humor and delivery you
know and so I mean each actor is
different they're just like human beings
you know so there's a trick to each one
of them whatever works you know some
actors have to be reduced others have to
be pushed and uplifted then it's a
process you know but good casting is key
it's all about the time you spend
looking I mean in my case I already knew
you are now because I met her ten years
ago casting for a film that never
happened but I knew I
somebody who had light who was like okay
I've got got to work with her
then with Thomas she was different the
guy who plays Victor the actor who plays
Victor he I just needed first I wanted a
musician who could act because isn't
this the magic of in actually performing
life between people and one I could sing
so if if I could find the pianist
musician who could also act so it took
me six months to realize that it's
impossible yes I went to all the actors
all the musicians and then I looked okay
but what I really need is an actor who
doesn't look like guy today who has a
certain period quality timeless quality
like somebody from the 50s a kind of you
know like Gregory Peck kind of you know
leading guy and and Thomas had that
although he wasn't quite aware he had it
you know it was like and then and then
you know I look for the somebody to play
catch Marek and there were like two
three contenders and I wanted to catch
Mike to be kind of you know they call me
careerist and I needed him to be to be
kind of likeable at some level and
childish dish too you know and so and
Boris should have had that quality is a
very comedic actor so I really kind of
like her suppress the suppress his
tendencies and so on you know each each
each relationship with an actor is a is
a thing in itself and you have to deal
with it there's no one formula I know
some directors have like a method you
know and they apply it equally to actors
and as a result the actors are totally
uneven on screen but there's not
criticize colleagues my takeaway is
though actors are like human beings
almost like just like human beings just
like humans
hero Kazi tell us about your casting
method I mean you're using non prose -
and you're mixing up with this you know
like like Kiki Karen who gives them a
phenomenal performance you've worked
with some of those people before how do
you how do you find those children how
do you how do you how do you work with
your actors every day what each one Oh
Matt audition no certain discrete
emotional or sheep I'll meet the key
military Ahmad - to meet a retainer
Authority not the Career Academy
so-called a call
Nanak coy ditched him at the surname or
soniku sonicu knee socket a - no cries
oh no kakera
cool nanny kaga detector is no material
kabocha pepper Martin or h-bomb
Ted McDonald a second e.g curry so no
cannot material is money I was at the
mat targeted but the cognizer know so no
that is much do you go to target
listening so talking about children when
i write the script and then look for
children I choose them through an
audition and I talked to each child and
I see how my talking to the child works
and then do they want to talk to me do
they want to work with me so there's
this sort of moment about how we
interact with each other and if it feels
right then I decide to put my money down
on that child so I'm going to bet on
that child and I'm and and then the rest
is a kind of a waiting game so you're
sort of waiting you don't want to rush
the child you
want to really be patient and let that
child unfold and through that process of
just sort of once you choose the child
the rest is just kind of waiting and let
it unfold and that's the way I work with
the children also this goes a little bit
to your your your writing filmmaking
process you I've read that you you know
you take their lives what's happening to
them like I understood like the the
child had a loose tooth so the next day
you had a you went home that night you
wrote a scene where she lost a tooth so
it becomes it becomes natural for them
to perform these scenes is that correct
yes Mac I don't get by the game but
takoto kokanee Sonakshi didn't above
committed emoji by knockout on Jeannie
no chance of 10 comas Odessa she sewed
and descoteaux
story no knock knock I need Oh Tory
Comerica oh hi Johnny
no no do story in cash a key to cut is
Thomas Kincade you know Hagen
come on Ohana get out too much to walk
in our College to see an austerity some
posters in the semi Omid skate semi no
yochim it's Kate Upton more automata
modest Russia score - shall be nominal
top ten more Ottoman and eskimo timber
sorry well Cikini no cos theta so that
that's correct
what quite correct that in a sense what
I do is that when something is for
example even the weather or the tooth
when something occurs then I even though
it's random and I haven't planned for it
I always think
can I pull this into the story so
something that was totally unexpected
rather than excluding it and saying well
that wasn't what I meant it to be I I
look at it and say well hold on what can
I do with this now so good examples of
that are the tooth that came out and so
I incorporated that into the script the
other one is the scene where the
children find the cicada the babies the
the infant cicada that's just come out
of the ground that was completely random
that was not in the script and also the
rainstorm when they get wet in the rain
storm and that also was random so those
were all things that just happened and
that I looked at and said you know what
I'm gonna keep these and see how I can
incorporate it into the whole for you
talk about casting you talked a little
bit about how you knew certain actors
you definitely wanted to have yes well
actually one actor anyway I definitely
want to happen that was the best call it
was you know normally I've always you
know if you even taught this at kind of
film schools where I said always only
write to the character don't think about
an actor as you're writing because it
can add a level of artificiality but I
of course broke that rule on this one
because I just couldn't think of anyone
else then Sebastian for this and all the
other actors I really found through a
very extensive auditioning and it was
very out of there's a very brilliant
casting director in in Berlin Ximena
beer and she has an incredible overview
of you everybody who acts in the German
language and has you know also done when
there's been German language actors in
American films be it you know grand
Budapest hotel or the reader or
inglorious basterds I mean that's all
her we I started working with her on the
on the lives of others and so she has a
really beautiful studio and we have a
set up and I tried out really hundreds
of actors but sometimes it's really you
know there was one actually for the lead
actor that I had in this one it really
made me rethink the whole casting
process and the whole auditioning
because so this actor is tom [ __ ]
was a an actor that I'd actually met
once when he was when he was still in
high school I was in film school and was
presenting my short films a festival he
was there with one of his first films as
a when he was a high school student and
I just remember meeting him and he kind
of impressed me as a and since I've
followed his his films and he hadn't yet
really had like a big breakout role but
he was very interesting and had this
interesting quality that it was just
compelling to watch him watching people
you know because he doesn't have much
dialogue in the whole film that
character and he's just painting and
observing people and is more of a sound
observer and that has to be more
interesting to watch but then when we
did the first audition you know it
wasn't it just wasn't there and we could
see it on the tapes and we were all
looking at the tapes and you know it
wasn't there and I said okay well maybe
it's you know this was just an unusual
situation for him or maybe he was you
know I mean I'm 6 foot 10 and he's not
particularly tall so that maybe he just
you know was scared by this enormous
person telling him what his ideas were
about the part so I thought okay let's
do it again but again it wasn't there
and then I said okay let's you know to
try it out with another actress and in
the process of that found actually this
wonderful my wonderful lead actress who
was just someone who came in to read
with him and then you know we went on
and on and it just wasn't there and then
my casting director was saying okay well
look he doesn't you know it's obviously
not well you know what you're looking
for but I I just felt that there was
something I wasn't doing right because I
his performance had moved me in other
films and then on the seventh I think
audition he actually when we were done
with it and you know it wasn't a good
audition either he handed me a letter
that he'd written beforehand and and
then I you know I thought okay he's
writing me look I can't go through this
anymore find someone else or something I
thought that was gonna be in the letter
but what he actually said in the letter
is you know fluorine I know that today
you know I wrote this before the
audition but I know you you will not
have seen what you were looking for and
I know that these auditions are bad but
you know so I I know exactly what you
want from this character I know what you
want from me but I'll tell you one thing
I cannot give it to you in an audition
situation because to give you something
that delicate and complicated I have to
feel wanted accepted loved and by
definition I can't feel that and you
know I can't be that in an audition so
just take it on faith I know how to do
this part I'm the best actor it take me
for the role and and it was really a
crisis of conscience because you know my
casting director was saying you were
crazy I mean it's only you know that's
why you do auditions you know you
obviously don't have it there's other
actors out there but I thought you know
it's just this is so much a film about
listening to that inner voice and you
know feeling something and I just felt
that it was true you know and and so I
called him and I said okay look III
understand what you're saying you have
the part and he said you know really I
didn't just seduce you with the letter
and I said well he did seduce me with
the letter but I also believe that it's
true so let's believe it and then and
you know from the first from the first
rehearsal onwards no actually from the
first from the first costume fitting
onwards it was right there this is a
really interesting thing that I have
with my amazing costume designer
Gabriella Binda Binda who's here also an
Academy member she is she has also did
the lives of others I mean this woman is
really incredible and the thing is she
has this thing that when she she'll know
what costume is right and once they're
wearing the costume it's all there you
know it's really interesting and and
then I have this you know then so it was
all there and you know Caleb and I knew
it from the first rehearsal onwards and
you know the interesting thing is at
that point then I don't try to you know
mold too much performances or so you
know because I thought there was this
wonderful Jeff Bridges gave an amazing
speech at the Golden Globes I don't know
if you listen to that when he received
his honorary award we you know
hero and Nadine and I were all there to
watch you win and and and we had and we
had you know and it was he gave this
amazing speech where he said where he
talked about we talked about how on his
very first film as a lead actor it was a
michael camino film and he'd and he went
up to
and he just before they were going you
know starting to shoot he suddenly had
doubts and knew he couldn't do the part
and and he talked about that in the
speech and he said he went to Jimmy nose
office and said to Jimmy know look I'm
sorry Michael I I know now I cannot do
this part I'm not right for it I think I
would destroy both your and my career
please you know I know it's late in the
game but you have to have to recast and
he says to me know was completely
unfazed and just said to him do you know
the game tag he says yeah I said well I
tagged you you're it you can do no wrong
any doubts you have are now the
characters doubts any strengths you have
are now the character strengths you know
you are the character and that I thought
so beautifully embodied you know I'd
never been able to phrase it like that
but that is so completely my philosophy
about acting I know that as soon as you
know I've tagged someone who has moved
me you know and and I only you know cast
actors that have really impressed me and
moved me and I really admire that art of
acting you know I and and you know III
don't I've never looked for kind of an
amateur actor or something like that or
a real person or something I really
believe in that art and skill and craft
and incredible art form of acting I feel
once I've chosen them I know it's there
it's in them you know and and and so I
just try to you know for us to find an
environment in which that's in which is
possible for that to shine I I really
see my job mainly as you know building a
beautiful stage for great actors to
teach us emotions you know that's
but just be warned because you you've
told that story on your next movie
you're gonna get a lot of letters okay
everybody who auditions for you I wanna
be the next day they're gonna have the
read the letter ready before they even
come in okay you leave the letter with
the secretary Alfonzo talk about your
cast and the performances in your movie
are just astounding there are two Oscar
nominations out of your cast and just
once again that the mixture in the
reality and the freedom I think you gave
your actors and a very you know precise
way of filmmaking can you talk about how
you worked with the actors and how you
found the actors the as I was doing a
film that I wanted to have people to
look as much as possible to the original
people then that was a tough loser sadly
the casting directors here and it was
that was a tough thing because yeah
there was some character that the words
have photographic reference and another
one was just descriptions that I will
give to him and and it was as important
how they looked with how they feel how
they felt and so it was like a year
probably close to hood of a year of
casting and you know we started getting
our our people that the elite said the
actor who plays clay came at the very
end and as always you're very stressed
because without that you have a film and
but it was very immediate when I met her
that she was the right choice but it was
a little bit like the the resting in
this film it was it was I didn't really
know what I was doing you know it was
the cast and the beam mostly of
non-professional actors some people had
never acted or having any intention to
act before so and the process was that
we shot in absolute chronological order
a so they were learning what the movie
was about day by day
and that helped a lot I mean we had the
location the main location with the
house and we had around the corner
another house like an holding area in
which the actors will have hangout but
following the structure of the family
they were called you know so they will
call each other
the characters names for instance and
some dynamic stark happening there and
it was you shall allow those dynamic
dynamics to flow when you were so doing
the scenes part of the game was about
nobody had I I would give specific
instructions to the different characters
the different actors confidentially I
never staged as a group and each
information would contradict the
information that I gave the other one so
it was about creating that chaos that
kills talking about and sometimes he was
it was too much it sometimes he didn't
work good sometimes it was it was just
happening and and I was just so lucky
that that I end up working with with
Marinette avira who plays Sofia and
jelly's Aparicio the place Clio that the
opposite sides of the spectrum Marina is
a highly well highly trained actor and
yeah Lisa had never done anything in
terms of acting but the for marina was
so difficult at the beginning to engage
into this process of chaos and fragile
Itza it was she the actors that they
know not to stay know that there was not
a normal process you know they were just
doing it and eventually whether it was
really magical for me was to see gel
Itza building on building building her
own character you know and really
understanding as I was learning her
character day by day really crafting
something very subtle with the character
so I'm just very grateful because a part
of what I had to do was just create the
chaos
and observe and see what happened I've
heard you tell the story of the the
birth scene like like the Lisa took it
to places that you didn't think it was
going to go can you tell that a little
bit here yeah as we were shortening
shooting in continue it in chronological
order you know we the scene before that
was her being taken into the into the
into the labor room in a stretcher and
and then I rehearse the sing without
Goleta with the act with the doctors
that are real doctors that's what they
do every day they deliver like I don't
know 12 babies a day so they knew
exactly what they were doing
and once that everything was staged we
just shot the scene yeah Lisa didn't
know what was going to happen and
actually she thought that we were we had
we had a live baby that who that we're
going to hidden under the table you know
that she's going and she was looking
forward to meet the baby and you know
and and her reaction is that's take one
you know sometimes you when you're doing
like this you cannot grow then I did
take two and the performance is amazing
that this is a testament of how great of
an actor is yalitza
but there was something immediate about
the first stage even if technically I
had my issues that I decided to take to
keep that first take here's a here's a
drill directors question what was the
hardest thing you had to accomplish in
your film weather obviously the hardest
thing usually raising the money not
raising the money but like what was them
it was there anything like what a day
you woke up with a knot in your stomach
where you're like how are we how am I
going to how am I gonna do this today
what was the what was the toughest thing
on shoplifters
I know can I come in Christian they go
to cut the budget chemo kokkonen
committee member decorate the mosquito
Coto de Arte dos uno three point boom
I don't scream oh hey Zuke taking it I
say God I can take my to see no need
sake not created to conquer it's great
much demon totemo doki Muhammad Atta can
Tony Alamos Korea no cry Osaka
so for many of the movies that I took in
the beginning of my career I did
struggle very much with money and
raising money and trying to make ends
meet but I have to say in the past five
years my films have produced good return
domestically and internationally in
terms of and the people that have been
working in the distribution have been
wonderful many of those people are here
today in the audience and so we have
developed a trust relationship over
these five years and created a stability
for myself so that I can produce one
film per year and I feel very fortunate
I'm very blessed that this reality is my
current reality I'm not sure how long it
will last but for now this is the way it
is Nadine I apologize I thought I began
the the question about the vision
design with you but I actually get to
answer that question in terms about the
the visual design of your film and
working with your scimitar AFER's and
things like that
never mind was i sleepy I'm sorry I'm
I'm falling apart here all right Florian
talk about that what was it was there a
tough thing that you had to accomplish
in your movie um you know I mean I'd say
one of the one of the tough things was
you know there one thing that was very
important to me was the the love scenes
in the movie and and I knew that I
wanted them to express something you
know I knew they would be these islands
of bliss you know as I as I as I looked
at them throughout the whole film that
in way these young people who are so you
know in a way they're just trying to do
good things and people from all sides
are attacking them and are
instrumentalizing them and so on but
they have this and they're you know
they're poor and they're being
maltreated from all sides but they have
this one in a way island of happiness
which is their consolation that's their
love and I wanted to express that
through these scenes of lovemaking and
that's you know that's not something
that's been done regularly over the past
years you know in some ways cinema has
become quite prudish and I find that's a
problem because so often that it needs
to express something and I also have a
problem with love scenes very often you
have a film that flows beautifully and
has a great story and then comes the
love scene and actually the story comes
to a full halt and you just have people
you know kissing each other feeling each
other up and you know rolling around in
the bed and then you go back to the
story and I didn't want it to be like
that you know I wanted them to be real
continuations of the story so I but I
knew this would you know I had very
young actors and you know who hadn't had
so much experience with with with
filming love scenes so I talked to them
about this in great detail but I could
see they were still a little awkward
about it so what I what I did is I then
found some you know some stand-ins who
you know free-spirited stand-ins
and and and and and and first and and
then actually rehearse the whole
choreography of a love scene because I
think what is so awkward about love
scenes so often fractures that you just
say oh you know now well you know do
something there and you know it's it's a
I mean you don't do that in other scenes
or you know at least I am so you know so
I thought it has to be just completely
choreographed and worked out so I worked
out the whole choreography with these
actors in a hotel room over three days
we have a production system sitting
outside and then Caleb came in for the
last you know like day or two and we
actually developed a whole in addition
to the choreography we developed exactly
how we were going to shoot that Caleb
shot it on it was amazing to see how he
was able to create a really cool light
just using you know his little hand
video camera and and actually masking
the hotel lights with tissue papers in
varying layers you know it was amazing
he actually created a very beautiful
intimate light situation and then we
filmed it and really figured out how it
was and then I showed the actors these
scenes with the stand-ins and said look
this is you know don't look at the
acting just look at the choreography you
know and I think that made them feel a
lot less awkward about it that they saw
okay you know what this is a regular
scene this is almost let's look at it as
a kind of you know ballet of love in
some way and and then and then I
actually also I said it so I think the
very first week that we have a shooting
was mainly love scenes because you know
it's something it was I think it was a
very good way for the actress to really
get to know each other and and and and
and you know and and you know and then
you didn't caught they didn't constantly
live in the fear oh my goodness week 7
comes that love scene so you know that
was in a way a hard thing to accomplish
but it was you know we're very very
happy with how that turned out and yeah
that's where the actors Alfonzo what was
the most difficult thing on you movie I
mean actually when I when I watch your
film that it's there's so many scenes
that this feel so real and so typical
like the scene we show tonight was the
beach scene and I just when I look at
that I get such a emotional feeling a
nice
imagine there being taked - you know I
can't imagine is like we're losing go
back to first positions get a dry suit
on you know what was what was actually
tough for you to shootin I guess that
they they the toughest thing was not to
fall into my old habits of trying to
preconceive too much and to control too
much or to find certain solutions that I
knew were effective I didn't care about
that I I wanted to try to find these
moments of existence but probably the
toughest thing is every morning every
morning this combination of excitement
and dread yeah and to overcome that
breath that usually is the drive to the
set and and and the joy for me comes
later is just the whole breaking there
you know jumping into the swimming pool
each day you know that is that the part
that is stuff you know whence that you
jumped then you can keep on swimming all
day long you know but this use that that
process at the beginning that that's
always kind of just - yeah - get rid of
that that's that feeling of dread Naveen
yeah I mean I think I feel the same this
dot is this knot in your stomach that
you're talking about it's just every
single day you wake up at 5:00 panic
attack you don't know what's gonna what
what will their day look like especially
in this film because it was a very risky
adventure the fact that none of the act
actors has had papers almost all of them
were illegal in the country and you know
waking up every day thinking you know
what's gonna happen are they gonna be
deported are they gonna be arrested are
they gonna show up maybe you know they
change their minds and
don't come and it was a very risky
adventure the whole thing so you sort of
the fact that we were scared for Zayn
the whole time every time he would go
back to his life I was you know all the
time thinking because I see how
difficult and how violent these kids are
you always think you know he's on the
verge of dying every day he's in danger
every day of his life so it was always
like that the whole time and it was also
of course a question of money
we started with no money and my husband
decided to produce the film and he
didn't have any experience producing you
know he's a music composer and apart
from the fact that he had to do this
whole amazing score he had to produce
the film at the same time and it was a
very very very difficult task for him
when we started shooting he didn't even
know what was the difference between
executive producer and a line producer
and co-producer so it was very tough
sometimes I would wake up in the middle
of the night and he is just wide awake
and I was panicking so how did what's
happening I need to pay the crew
tomorrow and I don't have any money
and so he ended up putting our house on
mortgage without even telling me in
order to continue this whole thing and
and and life kept sending us you know
guardian angels the whole time people
who would just enter into the into the
the adventure and helping us out from
here and there and we ended up finishing
the film we started it not knowing when
we were gonna stop when we were gonna
finish shooting and so you need to just
have this face that keeps you going and
my you know my executive producer he was
here Pierce Arif and Marianne Cottrell
was just like you know they were just
letting this adventure be and happen I'm
sure they were very much scared the
whole time but didn't really show it
because there was something that was
really pushing us into doing that whole
thing and we and we
and we're here now and believe I'm
sitting next to this guy paavo what was
the was the hardest thing for you to
accomplish but generally listening to
this you realize that all all
interesting things are usually very
close to disaster yes all on the brink
no and we all feel when we make our
films and work that is some guardian
angel because actually it goes against
all logic what you're doing in there and
it could go horribly wrong and I've
noticed old films that I've made that
kind of worked we're always on the brink
of disaster
well that's just general general
introduction no but everything was a
problem you know trying to redeem the
image with performance you know and how
do you make a actress float down the
river singing not drowning in the right
light you know where the light is just
at the right angle you know and you have
one maybe two Tate or you know that
final scene on the bench you know how it
has to be magical it has a great
location everything but and we have to
wait for the light just to be in the
right place and suddenly the wind
machine screws up and you know how
forget to win the machine no we need
that little bit of wind to come through
but then we're losing the light and the
actors are getting nervous you know his
permanent brinksmanship you know I'm
sure but generally you know this when
you try to combine the performance with
image with you know all in one it's it's
always a tightrope you know so that's
why I tend to do quite a few takes you
know in order to achieve something that
seems accidental and beautiful but
actually it's sort of scientifically
arrived that I want to ask you guys a
the the visual question that I that I
see what I thought I already asked I
mean all your films are just they're
there they look so they're visual feasts
but they range from documentary style to
to widescreen spectacle to black and
white even different different aspect
ratios you stick with you bobble and I'm
sure you've had the answers a thousand
times but what made you choose to
shoot Cold War in black and white in
that aspect ratio I know I have to find
a new concert and I know it's your last
it's last time you have to answer it I
just thought it was the right thing to
do
no but okay but in order to say a bit
more and I thought it was very good to
to limit the field of vision when I
injured limited it's very good for
portraits and faces were important in
this the aspect ratio black and white
because she opponent wasn't very
colorful let's say in you know late
fourth and early fifth season you know
whatever colors I could have imagined
they would have no not being that
interesting and I needed the film to be
punchy and dramatic and black and white
actually was a better way of making it
colorful and expressive so that's it
that's it more or less in shoplifters
what was your what was your visual what
was your visual design visual plant
proteome they create the keurig this the
kongamato kinesio concealed-carry da da
da da da da
ah no chica no ma y pantech innumerable
his own e eb Shimazu she conquer no naka
de Cecotto cote de Tomaso cornichons
kirakira stamina
cinto Steph Curry to erode a hematite
idea eternity maintenance rainy Sansa
washed
toko otome on Oct chemistry my central
dome oh-oh I go no naka de Mayo do see
me
[Music]
so when when I first started visualizing
this film I talked to the cameraman
and/or the cinematographer and we he
looked at the plot and he said to me
that he wanted to he visualized this
film as sort of a very realistic so at
the base as a very is a realism but at
the same time he wanted to make sure
that he added a sense of poetry to it
through the use of light and Colour so
the family and the children exist in a
very poor and not hospitable environment
but added to that is a kind of sparkle
so the light and the color create a
sparkle that at that lights up that
poverty almost like a fairy tale I'm not
sure I want to use the word fairytale
but there is that aspect to it so in
spite of the poverty there's the fairy
tale for example in one scene there's
the boy talks about swimmy which is a
book written by Leo Leone about a fish
that swims at the bottom of the ocean
and just sort of putters around and
discovers himself and I see the family
very much like that like fishes at the
bottom of an ocean fluorine you actually
already talked a little bit about do
your collaboration with
yes I mean Caleb and I spent a lot of
time in it since we shot in many
different places countless cities in
Germany and then also in Italy and in
the Czech Republic and in Poland
actually and wherever we went we would
always go to also in preparation we
would go to the local museums and and
and in a way choose many images as
guiding images for each sequence so you
know talked a lot about the horizon
lines and then also we looked through a
lot of photographs and so that since
this spans 30 years of time we would
somehow the respective arrows would the
colours of that would be reflected in
would reflect a little bit the state of
photography at that given moment in time
so that it has a little bit of that feel
on a subliminal level and you know so
you'd have in the 30s you'd still have
some of that sepia color and then you go
to a little D saturated colors later on
as we go into the West in the early 60s
you you go into a clear or white also
and these were all things that we
discussed with costume and production
design also so that everybody would be
working along those same lines you know
it's it was and then there was actually
also one really important aspect that
was one of the things that I actually
learned from my editor Petra Shore amel
was also here where did all my films and
she had this really interesting thing
that she always taught me from the first
film on order where she said there
should be no difference in how you
conceive a cut from how you conceive a
crossfade that the things have to you
know you can't say you don't know grow
straight you kind of expect that one
image has to go so perfectly with the
next one why do you have less of an
expectation for a cut so we really
conceived it also so that the images
from one scene to the next would really
go together and seamlessly move from one
to the next so we have a continuous
forward movement so it played into all
all different aspects and Alfonso you of
course you want to being your own DP on
this picture well what made you make
that decision how did that come about
because she will be
see here because of the schedule kept on
extending and again came very difficult
for him to do it and he kept on telling
me I'll like for weeks and weeks I
didn't went to here and there was a pond
he says yeah this is true I I won't be
able to do it and and then is when much
II he convinced me that I should do it
we have prepared together all this time
so and I have to say I had a blast I had
a blast I really enjoyed as I said
before you know in some other at some
moment is just the problem was that the
DP and the director didn't get along
they hate each other
but besides that it was it was really
because if the process of the writing
was going directly from memories into
page and then it was an unfiltered
process of going from the page into into
the image right the important thing here
was the collaboration with Athena
Caballero the production designer who's
here as well who because the field was
from the get-go one of the reasons I
wanted to explore this film was about
exploring time and space so the function
of of the camera was trying to register
that sense of time and space and the
best the first thing was the a very very
detail and long work that I did with the
venue and I'm for Elena to create these
spaces that had to have a lot of
information both character wise but also
in terms of a socio-political commentary
most of them or some symbolic metaphoric
elements that we will repeat throughout
the film and and then it was about
trying to to combine those things
actually the image was
about that about time and space and time
in the sense also of the flow of
allowing things to to expand to to text
it to take their own time you know not
in the past I always control time and
rhythm here was I wanted to put myself
at the mercy of that and and and
ultimately cinema is is about time you
know and I think that image is also
about time and I think is the first time
in my career that I really focus in that
in that element of I I felt always very
comfortable dealing with compositions
and setups and choreographies but it was
here was more about the sense of time
there was well was guiding everything
Nadine who I'm not gonna skip you this
time because my cinematographer is here
his name is Christopher Owen and he's
just amazing you know I when I started
when we started writing this script I
was always telling everybody around me I
dream of living this film with my
cinematographer living the preparation
with my cinematographer and he ended up
living in the apartment where we were
doing all the pre-production so I
literally was living this whole
adventure with the producer it's a
family if it was really a family affair
when I say it it was a real homemade
film really because we we took the first
floor of the building that we live in
and it was it became this is where we
did everything preparation and pre
production post-production music and
everything so he was living there with
my editor actually also yeah it was
really a family affair anyway so for me
it was for us both it was important to
live this together so we get to the
should wear weed and we don't really
have to talk a lot it becomes very
organic and it becomes something that we
really that a language that we
understand both of us very very quickly
and we decided that of course we were
going to shoot with available light most
of the time when we could when we can
because it had to be very realistic so
we had to be intervene the least
possible we this was the word on the
shoot we intervene the least possible
whether in lighting or even setup or in
everything we just decided we need to
blend in the most possible so we used
available light whenever we could and we
were very mobile so we had to shoot
handheld everything because we had to
really follow what was happening and we
knew that sometimes you know some things
were going to be improvised so if they
need to be very mobile so when you're
watching the making of they were doing
you know we had two cameras and when
you're watching them there were really
it was like a choreography they were
really dancing around the actors all the
time and Christopher really found
himself in very peculiar peculiar
situations sometimes in very peculiar
positions because he had to you know
find his place in order to capture this
moment of reality and especially when
you're working with children and you
have to be out there we decided that the
most of the time he had to be at their
level so it was it was very of course
difficult and very physically difficult
because sometimes you would shoot for
hours just to have a smile from treasure
or have a you know a certain reaction
from Zayn or so we had to be very
patient and physically it was it was
very very difficult but so those
decisions were happening really very
organically and we tried to be as real
as possible and as much as we could like
shooting like we were shooting a
documentary
with those moments that were more poetic
where you see it was like a sort of
withdrawal from the reality of what was
happening so where there was two kind of
shootings one that was very very hand
held very organic and one that was sort
of withdrawal from everything was like
like like a God's point of view on
things that was there was more poetic
and more structured and more I don't
know how to find the world more poetic
in a way yeah with this award
you guys are nominated your film is
nominated but also your country is
nominated and I'm wondering what the
what the reaction was back home when
when to all the attention the film the
film has received actually I talked to
you a couple weeks ago where you were
talking about when you won for the lives
of others what it was like to go back
with your award could you oh my goodness
yeah it's true you know i i i always
think actually at one point we even
talked about at the academy of doing
movie that it's just a little clip in
the way like Tornatore's edit that you
did hear of the various films where you
would have show the reaction in all the
countries I remember that when Tsotsi
won for South Africa I saw this image of
Gavin hood driving on on an open jeep
through the villages the desert villages
in South African you had thousands and
thousands of children running there just
wanting to touch the Oscar which he held
down like that from like this magical
object and we had when when I won for
the lives of others I remember there was
this I think it was in adult Mont in one
city there was they had actually done
this parade on the big square where they
had shaved the heads of a hundred people
had had covered them call a coloured
them gold and and and they were all um
standing there in freezing cold this was
right after the Academy Awards and I
walked through those you know right up
to the Town Hall it was this and with
thousands of people around anyway there
are all these images from and actually
was very funny because then I had the
award one of these guys was there
shivering Uli's muscular guys
to completely go with their heads shaved
and and and they'd all you know giving
up their hair to be on this television
program and and then he saw the statue
and said oh my goodness he has hair you
know the Oscar actually does have hair
but he looks bold from a distance anyway
you know it's just of course it has a it
has a huge impact in the country but
actually in a strange way we had this
thing that I you know in Germany for
example the lives of others was not
particularly successful until we
suddenly started getting nominated and
Wow you know we must have a good film
here and suddenly that got people to go
and see it in Germany so I think we have
the same mechanism happening right now
it's it would be it would be good if our
countries maybe were a little more
confident in their own opinion but but
everybody values the academies opinion
how is Mexico reacted to to Roma's
they're there in the house tonight there
you go no it's been the interesting
thing is that the film has opened a
whole discussion in Mexico about racism
about domestic workers and the films
being used as a platform for the
domestic workers organizations to to get
legislation so that is kind of that is
yeah same here in the u.s. thing is I
think that that's the interesting thing
also because of jalisa that is the first
timing which is a real representation of
in in call it mainstream film because
end up turning to be a mainstream film
of of an indigenous woman you know is
because and and the influence that she's
been to other people yeah it says so
smart I mean she's so incredibly smart
and sensitive that she understands the
symbolic symbolic value of herself right
now
and she's just not only doing with
dignity but really spreading the voices
and I think he said it was a discussion
that was a long time needed pretty much
centuries and yeah unfortunately and the
and you know this is I think it's a
moment in which the country has to
recognize itself as a racist country
yeah as a generalization but is the the
social structure is built like that and
that has that has been the most
interesting aspect of all of this have
they reacted Mele you know we don't have
one kind of reaction in Lebanon because
obviously some people don't want to
acknowledge also the fact that this is
happening in our country the same things
you know the situation of migrant
workers and domestic workers in Lebanon
that is very problematic unfortunately
it's almost like modern slavery the
situation of these kids that are on the
streets I mean the we we don't want to
those belts of misery that surround our
cities and and that we treat sometimes
as if they were invisible we don't want
to look we just keep going we just keep
driving and it's really here it's there
those slums those belts of misery that's
around or our lives we don't want to
acknowledge that so there's a lot of
people obviously that are don't want to
look themselves in the mirror they don't
want to see the flaws they don't want to
acknowledge that this is happening in
our own country because there's this
pride obviously that we do have and we
don't want to see it and but some other
people
have a very positive reaction towards
the film and they are acknowledging the
problem and they want things to change
and this film was made to ignite some
kind of change so now the film is
becoming at the discussion it's becoming
a debate among people a discussion among
people and and I think this is the way
to start the healing process we're not
gonna stop there
the film was intended to also is
intended to create some kind of
political mobilization also in order to
you know to lobby for certain to law
changes and all that so for me this is
what needs to be done right now and I
can see that it's starting in a way it
started you see the change in people's
reaction towards the film you know some
people tell me we we couldn't eat for
four for three you know hours after the
film we couldn't like I stayed in my
seat and I couldn't walk I I care I took
the film with me and I kept thinking
about it for a week I want things to
change what can I do to change I mean
you feel like this sort of change on a
personal level in the people that see
the film and this is what I I was
looking for when I made this film and
and I hope that it will you know ignite
some kind of true change then we're
gonna go back and start working on the
ground with the government with the
lawyers and judges and and try to find
solutions I mean maybe we will never get
there maybe we'll we will never find any
solutions but at least which we should
try at least yeah and pavo how was
Poland reacted
actually you're similar to him you you
you've won this category before what was
it what was the reaction the first time
it was what the hell's the reaction now
it was a mixed reaction to the first to
eat up it became a political
football slightly you know like that the
party that's now in power was then
fighting an election campaign and EDA
became a kind of argument for them that
that it's an ante published were they
nobody had seen EDA you know they're
like hundred and ten thousand people
went to see it in cinemas in Poland was
a black and white art house film that
usually just slips by unnoticed but
suddenly when it started getting notice
and winning awards and then the Oscar
then it became a fact in the landscape
and they said look at you know how I
mean people who are now in power
look at how Poland is misrepresented by
you know abroad by this so the country
was kind of divided not that anybody had
seen the film much anyway so mixed
blessing but but then the Oscar is an
Oscar you know in the end it ended up in
some Museum and watch which is a
Hollywood Hollywood a main you know
cinema city and then there were
pilgrimages to actually see the thing
and to touch it you know so sorry no one
was painted gold
nobody was so bald men came painted go
no no but they were just checking
whether it's gold and and you know why
why was so heavy they didn't realize
that it's the bottom did that's heavy no
it's not the it's not the gold anyway
and there were this one you know there's
a lot of fuss of course you know that
Yama's village is being haunted by here
by journalists and sensation seekers and
they kind of trying to interview her
sisters brothers local innkeeper the
same with the DP Mukesh was this you
know he comes from a small small town up
north you know so suddenly the local bus
driver remembers the walkers to school
I'm staying out of it so you know yeah
so there's a little bit of folklore you
know and the whole country is kind of
living it as if it was some kind of
Olympics coming up you know I'm trying
to this Quran is gonna win anything
everything anyways and in Japan what is
this what has been the reaction for you
and the film I know total mo boku no
naka de nada de ichiban taxonomy today
so no energy only me to my any so
imbricated
mommy - she never a crash - because of
konohana [ __ ] - but I know she's in no
tank idea Shimano oh you know so today
javis here talkin to you know inaudible
campaign ang and I cut Tiana
he hung - you got a sheen I do you need
to talk a demo Coco Saratoga
art master ahsoka ahsoka denied oh you
are a sensation a in order to you which
taught at Chickamauga que esta 100 di
giotto Chanel career Amato she died
Sunday she minutos de casa Katie good to
you missing iguana no Fanny Agatha's
Murray nan desu kedo so no me siento
Nagi Managua an okinawan on 8hd
mikoto I know change master
America Chile Montana kappadisco oh no
no no she saw what I decorated Erica
Cerritos so no Hannah move comedic Onaga
EEMA little to no studs no amina no
cannot do you Katya no cannot oh honey
Imam I'm a guinea tinnitus actually I
want to say thank you to the translator
you've done an amazing job tonight I
haven't got through this yet so I would
say for the most part the reaction to
this film in Japan has been really
wonderful
we had 3.8 million people come and see
the film just in Japan I believe that
certainly part of that was the Palm D'Or
from Cannes Film Festival but it has
been very well received and then there
have been a few voices often over the
internet that have said other things so
for example they say there's no such
thing as a family that could be kept
together by shoplifting and besides why
would you want to show that that's
shameful you're creating a negative
image of Japan and then others would say
oh that doesn't exist it's all your
imagination so they just want to deny it
that such a family couldn't really exist
and so it's interesting that the
viewpoint in the film itself is sort of
ultimately denial is saying that can't
exist or that shouldn't exist and that
viewpoint did exist in the comments of
some people not everyone but some people
on the internet really wanted to say it
doesn't exist it's not real and so it
was very interesting that that came up
and and so in a sense
the reaction was very much about not
valuing what was in that film don't read
the internet that's really the lesson
don't read the comments that's really in
general though I think it's a great
question to go out on I really want to
thank you all for your films thank you
all for this lively discussion ladies
and gentlemen the Oscar nominees for
Best Foreign Film thank you very very
much thank you very much
[Applause]